all right uh hello everybody this is
Nick Gillespie with reason this is our
weekly live stream I'm joined by my
colleague Zach weismiller Zach hello
good to see you good to see you too and
we are uh joined today by the actor and
documentarian Alex Winter whose new
movie is the YouTube effect Alex it's
good to talk to you again
it's always good to talk to both of you
we have been uh you have been directing
for about 30 years right didn't your
first feature movie I believe came out
in 1993 that you directed and started
yeah I think it's scary to say my first
professional directing job started in
the mid 80s so it's getting close to 40
which okay maybe let's just stick with
30. yeah okay it was a lot less scary
yeah it's uh you know but in any case uh
you have done documentaries in
particular over the past 15 20 years uh
downloaded which was a great study of
Napster and unauthorized file sharing uh
the Deep Web a look at Ross Albrecht and
the Silk Road uh trust machine the
Panama papers and then I think most
recently was Zappa which came out about
three years ago about Frank Zappa as a
kind of ultra individualist Free Speech
activist technological Savant Etc
um we are now uh talking about the
YouTube effect your new movie that's out
uh Zach Let's Play the trailer and then
we're gonna come back and talk with uh
Alex about what's in the movie
[Music]
web giant Google will pay 1.6 billion
dollars to gobble up YouTube via the
making of YouTube Here's your new key to
new office
there was no doubt in in my mind that
this was going to be a huge trend of the
Future YouTube celebrities are laughing
along with their fans all the way to the
bank it's keyed Ryan who owned 22
million dollars this year they want
growth growth growth everything's about
growth they are obligated to maximize
shareholder value
add money that really affects the kind
of
kind of they're lost for hijacking
people's attention you just have to get
eyes on the video
everything on YouTube changed when the
recommender algorithm was introduced
it's not just algorithmic it's very
deliberate I'm a weapon I'm made to be
thrown at you I think YouTube is very
intimate format you're watching one
person talk to you when they start
telling you about their beliefs and
Views that pack a real punch now we're
in the sort of misinformation apocalypse
I don't agree that it is just reflection
of society it's changed Society this is
just made up by Bill Gates in them go
online and look it up it's kind of
dangerous how we are just waiting for
there to be enough of these digital car
crashes in this digital intersection
with no stoplight
if we don't figure out this problem
we're gonna lose what it means to be
human
all right that's the trailer the movie
is playing in Select theaters around the
country around the world and it's going
on streaming services so you can watch
it I highly recommend that you do but
Alex as a starting point what is the
YouTube effect or what are the effects
in particular that you're trying to
bring attention to in the documentary
I think it's the societal impact I think
that uh when I was digging around in
this community which is now by far the
largest online community on the planet
by a lot a lot bigger than anything
that's in its rear view mirror
uh I felt that there wasn't really a lot
of examination on Google and its media
platform YouTube which is what YouTube
is it's really Google's media front end
um and I felt as if the uh the societal
impact of that platform now that it's
been around long enough and it's so big
and pervasive globally
um was really beginning to uh to attempt
to unpack that to have a very close look
at that and Galen heard the producer
um uh had come to me and asked me if I
was interested in collaborating with her
on the story uh she had some access she
knew I would have access and it had
obviously been on my mind for quite some
time in my mind for probably a solid
decade uh in terms of its significance
and and its impact so it felt like a
good time to to jump in yeah what you
know can you just very quickly sketch
the
um well actually Zach why don't you run
through some of the numbers because
it's fascinating to think about you know
when and you said oh I've been directing
movies for 40 years it's like I remember
a time before I had a computer I
realized I'm like you know a mammoth or
I guess a mastodon these days like a
dying breed
um but the just to think about the world
before YouTube is like a radically
different place Zach I'm sorry run
through uh no I mean what's the reach of
this yeah you you mentioned it's
tremendous growth this is the first kind
of slide that appears in your movie you
mentioned December 2005 YouTube
officially launched over 2 million video
views per day a month later that reaches
25 million views today it has over 2.6
billion users worldwide uh it's the
second most visited website by traffic
in the world as of June 2023 right
behind Google you described it as the
front end of of Google so in a way
Google's got the one and two spots there
uh it is the second most popular so
social network worldwide right behind
Facebook Facebook at 2.9 billion users
uh YouTube as we mentioned a little over
2.5 billion users uh and the the this
data here is from kind of their one of
their in recent internal reports uh put
together by Oxford economics that looks
at the economic impact of YouTube and
according to their internal report here
uh their creative ecosystem has
contributed over 35 billion dollars to
U.S GDP in 2022 that's not counting kind
of YouTube's parent company that's just
the the platform that creators and then
YouTube's creative ecosystem has
supported they claim more than 390 000
full-time equivalent jobs uh in the US
so you know given that that meteoric
rise that explosive growth
of I mean first of all what do you think
explains that how why did YouTube grow
so quickly out of the gate
I think there's a number of things at
play and I think some of those are
actually good things uh and I think to
credit Susan majiski all the way back in
the day because she wasn't
obviously just the CEO of YouTube but
she isn't now she was when we made the
film
um she's stepped down subsequently but
she was also
an instrumental part of of the the
formulation of Google itself and uh a
big part of of how Google Rose
um and very very smart and uh very
forward thinking and I think that Susan
saw in this fledgling little video
platform what a lot of other people
didn't which was to a degree the future
uh you know we had Napster we'd uh we'd
had
um a sense by then that the world was
moving online and that media was moving
online and I think it was obvious to
people like me on mapster in 1998 1999
so it would certainly have been obvious
to anyone inside Silicon Valley if it
wasn't obvious to most folks elsewhere
um and I think what what what Susan saw
and then what she subsequently had the
hand in building with uh Steve Chen and
Chad uh Hurley who were the two of the
three founders of YouTube and then went
on to run it for a while
um was that this wouldn't just be a
Facebook it wouldn't just be a kind of a
video jukebox of which there were many
back in those days if you you know like
Nick and I are old so we remember we
remember I don't know what it was like
to I still miss audio Galaxy I'm not
gonna lie there you go exactly and Win
app I'm gonna go I'm gonna actually you
know so uh so there was a lot of these
things floating around but um nobody in
those days the real the winners of the
in of the tech space were going to be
those who figured out how to put their
arms around most of these tools and then
make them very easy for users to
navigate and use
um which is what YouTube was so it I
think there was an understanding that it
could become uh a video platform for for
uh users to upload their own stuff a
social media Community which is a
component of that a place for
entertainment for for visual and audio
entertainment a place for creators it
would then be monetized because they
started monetizing their creators very
early Smosh who were two of the first uh
creators of Fine Brothers uh you know
early on began to monetize almost
immediately in in significant ways they
were built you know all four of these
guys were teenagers practically and
began to earn a very good living so uh I
think that the the division for it was
there and I think that the willingness
to create an infrastructure that would
that would equitably and fairly pay
um content creators all over the world
right of every color of every ethnicity
of every uh type of gender
um it was really uh radical uh what they
set out to do in that way
um and what it has grown into now is by
far the largest media platform on the
planet yeah I think it would be well
useful especially for some of our
younger viewers who might not remember
those earliest days of YouTube to just
Glimpse back at a second as to what it
used to look like it was very you know
before monetization and
professionalization was very much just
like your amateurs uploading just a dumb
video you took and kind of the the
primary I mean we can just look at the
very first video that was put up the one
of the founders kind of set the tone for
early YouTube uh the uh this is
the elephants
and what these guys explain is that they
have really really really long
um
and that's that's cool
[Music]
and that's pretty much all there is to
say
so no no disinformation there that is an
absolute truth elephants do have a lot
of drugs absolutely that's got a I think
a couple hundred million views uh racked
up by now but
um you know uh we want to talk about uh
you know before we get into some of the
negatives that your documentary raises
could you talk a little bit about
YouTube's upsides what are some of the
the best contributions to I know our
culture to video and filmmaking that you
think uh YouTube has made over the years
there are so many uh and Google as well
and I I sort of mentioned them in the
same breath because they really are one
company even though there are elements
to YouTube that that are separate um
uh they are really one company with with
a with a single ethos and uh and the
kind and I'd say the positives of that
are are a commitment to
um to Innovation and kind of human
evolution using the culture itself
uh as its primary product and I think a
lot of that has been
extremely vitally important to Global
culture um in in some ways so in such
vast ways that it's almost diminishes
its power to start to break apart little
things like oh it's helpful to figure
out how to put AAA batteries into the
back of your radio it's like you know it
gives you like mundane information well
it's also the repository of basically
all a visual human content that's ever
existed since the dawn of content being
recorded in any form and even not
recorded um you know but re-implemented
in some form another by the way of
explainers so it's it's our last it is
our library Alexandria I know that's a a
terrifying concept especially to
Librarians because there is so much
misinformation there but there were
there were a lot of missing for there
was a lot of information in the Library
of Alexandria too right there was and
there's a lot of misinformation in your
in your local public library so that's
just
my point is
where I get kind of of you know uh
disconcerted by the way we look at at
the rise of new technology having been
around these stores for a long time is
we other it right it's this other thing
but it's not another thing it's really a
natural evolution of human uh Innovation
and these are tools that that we have
evolved to create
um and they're just a part of the fabric
of Being Human so YouTube specifically I
would credit them with as I said earlier
with very specifically and intentionally
monetizing the democratization of
culture something that we saw happening
with Napster that the record industry I
would argue still has not successfully
done as well as YouTube has done I would
even argue that my industry which is on
strike right now has not figured it out
as well as YouTube has uh you can you
can create on YouTube you can be a trans
you know African artist in a in a micro
nation and make a crazy good living if
you have access to these tools and can
uh you will get monetized you'll build
an audience you'll you the gates are
down your reaching people all over the
world and so that's an amazing thing
that I think they did intentionally and
very successfully I think the breadth of
information is vitally important to have
at the fingertips of anyone around the
world just removes gatekeeping and it
removes uh it democratizes information
yeah unless you're in China where they
can literally censor you right and I
mean just to kind of build on that the
you know one of the early Sensations on
YouTube was watching Chinese kids uh lip
syncing to the Backstreet Boys songs and
things like that and it created you're a
gangman style the rise of K-pop yeah I
mean it created a a global village right
that Marshall mcluhan could only kind of
speculate about in the 60s and it built
off of the you know those signal
developments in the 90s that were a lot
of it was around the internet
um but it was other you know just the
the decreasing price of uh technology so
that you know the the cost produce and
consume assume culture under whatever
circumstances you wanted whether as
authorized unauthorized legal illegal
all became much cheaper I just you know
part of The Upside for us and reason was
we went online uh with reason TV uh as
it was called in October 2007 we've been
on YouTube since 2007 and we've had
something like 255 million views of our
over 3000 videos that we've put up we've
only made about uh five hundred thousand
dollars all told so it's not like we're
making a living out of it but you know
it's better than zero but that idea that
you can bring together information
shared and distributed and it might find
a global market as humongous uh you know
one of the kind of examples in this it
seemed like it wasn't that long ago but
it actually was kind of but Coney 2012
is an example of a documentary which
there's a lot of reasons to be you know
critical of it but it was about a
warlord in Africa who had a child Army
that became a massive Global phenomenon
in 2012 and it kind of shows the power
of YouTube to kind of galvanize people
in ways good and bad
um the you know your
um
um the the you know and you you touch on
this the uh YouTube one of the most
popular things on it are explainer
videos and how-to videos you know and
that has gone massively large but let's
talk a little bit about you know the
negative sides that you roll out about
YouTube in this because this documentary
is not really a celebration of YouTube
as much as a critique of it so uh Zach
do you want to talk about I mean maybe
we should start talking with about the
rabbit hole problem uh this uh gentleman
who I brought a slide up of is Caleb he
posted a video here called my descent
into the alt-right pipeline he's a major
character featured in your documentary
what does Caleb's story exemplify for
you
well it actually exemplifies that we're
Beyond The Rabbit Hole um that there was
a period when the YouTube recommender
algorithm uh was aggressively uh
propagandizing viewers because you could
go on if you had a predilection to look
at you know a a an influencer that had a
certain type of rhetoric that was fairly
benign uh you could very quickly get uh
recommended much more extreme uh
influencers and content that would that
would as the term uh illustrates would
take you down a rabbit hole it's very
difficult to get Rabbit Hole today
um they did in In fairness to YouTube do
a lot of work on that algorithm
um in fact with Caleb kind of as a as a
test case
um we didn't put this in the films it
was pointless but when I filmed him
which was at the Watergate Hotel because
we're we're cheeky like that
um we uh we did a a test with him where
um I had him go on his laptop and try to
Rabbit Hole himself and he couldn't the
algorithm just wasn't going to do that
and so the reason I was interested in
Caleb was Caleb you know was already on
his way to towards extremist
um views and YouTube and the influencers
they had on there at the time which were
very aggressively extreme extremists uh
like Stefan molyneux who was a big part
of the influence of the uh the shooter
and the in the Christchurch New Zealand
shooting was heavily influenced by
Stefan that got stuff on the platformed
eventually
um but it was really about where we are
post this Rabbit Hole idea the whole
idea that misinformation is so
proliferate the monetization of
propaganda is so proliferate now
um in our current culture that we're
almost all being Rabbit Hole or almost
all uh sort of in a blase way accepting
of of misinfo or flat out disinfo
um and in Caleb's case he was kind of
pulled out of that extremist Thinking by
another person on YouTube which was
Natalie Wynn uh which we used to kind of
prove a point that you know the the some
of the Harms are here but a lot of the
antidote for those harms can be found in
the same place can be found in YouTube
itself
yeah at one point you actually quote
Caleb is saying I wasn't radicalized by
YouTube I was already radicalized but he
was talking about that the videos that
he was watching killed his empathy but
then he comes across Contra points uh as
she is better known and it's kind of
fascinating that you know
to to see uh YouTube is is not you know
an engine of disaster or to the extent
that it is it also becomes an agent of
empathy as well
exactly I think that that that's really
exemplifies the internet itself it's the
it's the whole spectrum of human
um experience the the issues to focus on
the harms and what I wanted to get at in
the film was hey I wanted to put a human
face on all of these issues because I
think that's important and that's what
docs are very good at you can read a
million articles about YouTube and about
social media and see a million
documentaries that don't really humanize
a core cast of characters that give you
an emotional understanding of the issues
at play
um and so from the people who actually
experienced it not like actors or
reenactments or something so uh that was
very important to me but I also wanted
to get past this idea of the algorithm
which in in my opinion is kind of a
diversion tactic by these monopolized
tech companies to just flood you with
confusing Tech rhetoric that just makes
the average person's eyes glaze over and
then you never get into the details of
how you can maybe make these places work
better
um and yes there are algorithms and yes
there are a lot of Engineers who need to
be working on algorithms but most of us
are not Tech Engineers most of us are
including the people who run Google and
YouTube are just people with basic
incentives
um and there was these basic incentives
that I was most interested in focusing
on with this film which in this case is
their business model which is an ad
Revenue based business model which is
attached is a dollar to content that
holds you on platform and to them just
like the yellow journalists of
yesteryear
um as we all know the most salacious
type of content is normally the most
ad-friendly and that is the case with
YouTube in a way that I think is
problematic so you mentioned that now
things have changed and you even tried
to get Caleb to Rabbit Hole himself and
could not does that indicate to you that
something shifted in the the incentives
is that that the advertisers start to
get uncomfortable with the kind of press
that YouTube was getting and therefore
they decided to shift the algorithm I
mean how how did the business model work
to sort of correct itself in this case
it's the opposite
um it's the opposite of of it getting
better of there being less harmful
information of advertisers getting wary
what it what it was was that the they
don't need to Rabbit Hole you to get you
to watch salacious content this
information is now pervasive right I
mean I have friends who are on all sides
of the political aisle who flirt with
extremely bananas uh theories of either
Flat Earth or just very cockamami ideas
about about the world that are not
fact-based the sort of non-fat-based uh
culture is pervasive so you don't need
the incentives aren't there to to force
you algorithmically
um into this kind of towards this kind
of content as Joe Pulitzer knew in the
late 1800s it's just human nature right
you you are you are pre you are
pre-wired to connect more intensely with
hyperbolic angry negative content than
you are with middle of the road fact
based content so it actually they don't
need to do that it's really a human
issue it's the parasocial relationship
of having someone looking into a webcam
like I'm looking at you guys and you're
looking back at me it's that very human
non-algorithmic parasocial component
that makes YouTube so powerful yeah and
when you but when you attach that to
content then you can monetize that yeah
when you say it's it's you know negative
or you know in hyperbolic and things
like that how does that explain you know
the emergence of somebody like Mr Beast
on YouTube who's one of the largest
um you know channels uh and characters
and it's if anything it's relentlessly
upbeat it's like Barney the dinosaur you
know post uh uh you know uh going
through uh puberty or something like
that
um is it actually is it negative like
salacious negative hyperbolic is that
the is that how they keep people
watching or is it more catering to what
people are interested in
I think it's both I think that when you
deal with with media a media platform as
big as YouTube of which there is no
larger media platform right
um you're going to be targeting
massively uh disparate demographics uh
Mr Beast uh for instance my middle
school kid loves Mr Beast and all of his
friends in Middle School of Mr Beast but
I've never watched a single Mr Beast
video in my entire life and neither have
my two older children not one not a
single one so
um you're just talking about about
demographics and I think that's where
it's a business model problem because to
to advertisers are looking at a pie
chart of numbers and they're not
differentiating at all between Mr Beast
and Stephen Crowder right but of course
there is a difference between Mr Beast
and Stephen Crowder because Mr Beast is
like doing this kind of benign you know
whatever coming and earn a million
dollars by jumping off this bridge and
Stephen Crowder is calling for civil war
after the FBI goes down to Mar-A-Lago to
look at Trump's classified documents and
and to an Advertiser it's just it's just
data points it's the same can I uh
before uh uh Zach has a clip that he's
gonna run but just before we move on
from the question of misinformation or
disinformation I agree with you uh
absolutely that most of my friends
believe things that are insane and not
fact-based sometimes they get support
from books sometimes they get support uh
you know from videos or you know maybe
even from recent articles or something
like that but how do you define that
um in a way that doesn't just become I
don't agree with this and hence it is
disinformation or it's misinformation or
it's Mal information and needs to be
called out
there are very clear-cut definitions to
the difference between misinformation
and disinformation that are generally
used misinformation essentially refers
to uh information that is untrue but
maybe benign it may be an accidental
mistake it may be
um a fact that is incorrect
disinformation is ideologically
manufactured to uh with an agenda so it
is not so much that this is where I
think it gets misconstrued by the public
or when we get into like I I would argue
um kind of Mis misunderstanding the
first amendment of free speech issues
disinformation is intentionally targeted
information that it that is literally
ideologically manufactured to create a
response it is it is actually propaganda
and a lot of the dark money
um funded influencers on YouTube that
are pumping out disinformation have very
specific political ideologies that they
are that they are servicing so it isn't
accidental and it isn't something that
ends up getting contextualized is by the
end user it is it is created
intentionally for X effect I think the
Crowder example is a good one I think
that that inciting your you know four
million viewers uh to Civil War uh based
on a completely legal
um and fairly casual uh visit to our
ex-president by an FBI member based on
class of information which is no
different than they would do to a
Democratic president
um or a different Republican member uh
that is a very good example of
disinformation that's harmful
to return to the uh Contra points
Natalie win example for a second because
what I find really interesting about
that channel and about what Natalie is
doing there is
she's kind of embracing this landscape
that you're describing or just like this
is she's just accepting like this is the
water we're swimming in it's a very
personal medium and um she just directly
engages with the culture War arguments
dissects the dishonest rhetoric and kind
of jumps into the arena instead of
sitting on the sideline begging YouTube
to de-platform or demonetize people and
does it in a very stylized way as we can
see here this is kind of the aesthetic
established that's designed to maximize
engagement kind of do what you need to
do on YouTube to reach an audience and
reach outside of an echo chamber and
build a following and in this case
there's evidence that that approach is
an effective tactic what is your
takeaway from what's the Contra points
channel has done
takeaways and I think this is Natalie's
having spoken to her about it is that
you work with the tools you have
um so I think when you have something
that has four I mean YouTube has 4.6 or
4.7 billion video views per day
so there's a lot of people who don't
have the tools at Natalie's disposal
Natalie's working with what Natalie has
to be involved I know that Natalie that
Contra points is very
um supportive of Civic engagement and
Civic response
um so you know she has been able to
build up a massive audience on YouTube
which is extremely rare I would I would
also add
um so there it is not by any means the
only tool that people should be using
Carrie Goldberg is using the tools at
her disposal as a lawyer to literally
create lawsuits and go after
um for for very specific arms based on
very specific issues on platform
um so I think it's incumbent I mean my
general opinion is it's all hands on
deck
um I think that because and and to be
fair to Google including Google hands on
deck right um and including pictures
from within their own company
um which are basic I just think that
we've never seen in human history uh
company this is Industrial Revolution
the digital technological Industrial
Revolution that we're currently in has
moved accelerated Pace the likes of
which we've never seen so we're all
playing catch up a little bit
and the yeah you know YouTube's uh CEO
or I guess outgoing CEO Susan buchinski
last year was talking on all the this
very topic uh in Davos at the world
economic Forum uh in 2022. I want to
play a clip from that just to get a so
everyone can get a sense of how YouTube
is thinking about this you know from the
top uh and then get your reaction to
the proposals that are being laid out
there
investing a huge amount to make sure
that we're fighting misinformation and
there are a number of different ways
that we look up at this so the first
would be from a policy standpoint we
would look at content that we would
think about in terms of being violative
of our policies so if you look at covid
for example we came up with 10 different
policies that we said would be violative
like an example of that would be saying
that covid came from something other
than a virus and we did see people
attacking 5G equipment for example
because they thought that it was causing
covid and the second one would be really
raising up authoritative information so
if you are dealing with a sensitive
subject like news
Health Science we are gonna make sure
that what we're recommending is coming
from a trusted well-known publisher that
can be reliable if there's content
that's borderline
content that technically meets our
policy but is lower quality that's
content that we basically will not
recommend to our users our users could
still access it and then lastly we're
just really careful about what we
monetize so we always want to make sure
that there's no incentive so for example
with regard to climate change we don't
monetize any kind of climate change
material so there's no incentive for you
to keep publishing that material that is
propagating something that is generally
understood as
not accurate information
so taking down really blatant uh
disinformation like that 5G towers are
called are causing uh covid-19 uh you
know d-ranking certain sources up
ranking authoritative sources and then
demonetizing controversial debates that
she believes are spreading
misinformation is that an agenda that
you think is a positive one for YouTube
to be pursuing
I think it would be great to see them do
that
so they're not they're not doing it no
okay no they're not doing that yeah but
here here's my reaction to to that
because I I do think it's
totally understandable and appropriate
for a company like YouTube to not want
videos about 5G conspiracies running
rampant on a platform I don't agree with
that though that's not true they're
actually incentivized to have a lot of
material like that in fact Google came
under Fire over the last few weeks in
terms of how it's it's spending their ad
dollars and not spending them in areas
that they told their advertisers they
were spending them
um so no I would actually argue that
they that while philosophically they may
not like the idea that they're
monetizing this type of content they are
absolutely monetizing this type of
content but they they have taken those
that sort of stuff some of them you can
find all that stuff it's all that stuff
is there on YouTube all of it is there
right the flip side to all this is that
I've seen what happens when you know
misinformation has become somewhat of a
buzzword and I've seen what happens when
the net uh is cast too wide I mean even
reason on TV we got a strike uh for this
is a video I produced it was about these
biohackers attempting to kind of create
a knockoff uh covered vaccine and was
called medical misinformation I mean I
just happen to know the fact that this
was not MediCal misinformation it was me
reporting on something somebody was
trying to do but it got caught and it
was like
six seven months after it went up that
it got caught in this drag net yeah and
so that is the that's the kind of
impossible thing about regulating
misinformation at scale you know whether
you're a government or private company
how do you call I don't think that's
true though I don't think impossible is
the right word I think that it's early
days and oftentimes because these
companies aren't incentivized to police
themselves they do it very badly and
they do it with a with a blunt Hammer as
opposed to a scalpel and it is early
like because for sure Zach there are
people who create music on on YouTube
who get their own content flagged like
really even beyond the example you just
gave like yeah really we we are
constantly being accused of infringing
or on copyright exactly that happens all
the time now I will this we would need
five hours for this conversation I will
tell you and you know how I feel about
this stuff I made the Napster movie yeah
I will tell you that that using
copyright nip law in this area to try to
rectify this stuff is generally
disastrous right and I will and so I'm
not like some big you know let's just
come down on everyone with with harsher
copyright law it will generally hurt the
folks that you're trying to help and
help the folks that you're trying to to
get protection from just the way those
laws are constructed
um so I'm not sitting here saying that
stuff is easy but I will tell you that
it's a heck of a lot simpler than people
are making it out to be and you have to
start somewhere so yes a lot of the
tools right now are very blunt but they
will definitely get less blunt as we go
along and we certainly don't want to do
nothing
yeah can I ask about that because you
know in in a way it seems like you're
you want to bring back or maybe you know
I realistically probably has never gone
away but this idea that there's a
guardian class that must control what
people are exposed to because they
really can't handle things they can't
sort things out themselves
um and you know this goes back to when
the novel was introduced when radio was
introduced movies you know comic books
Etc rock music in particular you know
and I think about uh you know your
documentary on Zappa you know this is
relevant with there's certain types of
material which should not be permitted
um because it will have a negative
effect on people who can't understand it
or can't critique it
um is there you know is there a
contradiction in what you're saying
between you know your earlier work and
your kind of emphasis on people being
allowed to express themselves no because
I think we're talking talking about
there's an enormous enormous
um spread there and I think that if
you're with disinformation being
information that is specifically created
to cause harm
um those are basic safeguards I don't
think there's a lot of that doesn't
enter sort of free speech territory
um you know if someone's being called
upon to go kill trans people and someone
goes and kills a trans person no I I
think it you know well if it's I mean
there's fighting words and true threats
that are you know have been worked
through yeah right but I mean it does
showing the impact of fighting words on
actual fighting and I think that that is
where the arguments for everything being
fair game are not valid
um so I mean and so like when Stephen
Crowder says we need a civil war because
my
you know God you know boy God Trump is
being uh investigated by the uh the FBI
that that crosses a line that if
somebody's saying you know what we need
a total reordering of society based on
recent political events that would be
sure I mean it's also intentionally
being done and funded by by some by dark
money interests that are trying to
create these Harms in this violence you
know as we saw with the Trump indictment
from yesterday the intention with the
January 6 Insurrection was to kill the
enemy it was actually to commit that
violence more people were radicalized to
go to the January 6th Insurrection by
YouTube than any other internet based
platform that is a a study with actual
numbers attached to it so you've got to
start somewhere
there's yeah I'm not I'm not convinced
of that I mean January 6 was organized
in you know WhatsApp groups Facebook
groups I mean private you know uh
encrypted Communications the people who
shut up the proliferation of the
ideology was proliferated by YouTube I
mean the Bella cam study is is very
comprehensive
uh yeah
you know the there there's
um the near the end of the film you
start introducing some possible policy
prescriptions you bring up the famous
internet law or you know very uh you
kind of Bedrock internet law section 230
of the communications and decency act
and uh that uh is essentially says that
platforms are not liable for user
generated content on their platforms uh
you know whether or not they moderate or
don't moderate just you know getting
involved with moderation does not mean
you're suddenly liable for every single
thing that someone posts on your
platform
this has been something that's been
attacked by both Democrats and
Republicans and your film seems to also
uh call for some sort of Reform needed
around section 230 what is what is it
that you would like to see changed about
that that fundamental law of the
internet
um actually it doesn't uh the film
doesn't do that
um in fact I would argue that we that
our general take
um not that might take is that important
because we're really just trying to show
all sides around this debate but section
330 is an incredibly difficult uh thing
to reform and it is really what provides
the safeguards for the internet period
um and tampering with it in a uh in a
blunt way would actually as I said
before cause harm to the very people
that
um that we that many people would be
looking to protect and it would it would
hyper Empower uh the monopolies there's
a reason why certain factions in
extremist sides of of political thinking
want to abolish 230 because uh it would
essentially
um allow for an enormous amount of
censorship
um and it would erase enormous amounts
of content from the internet that is
providing very important
um uh views and and giving voice to
people who need Voice who would not have
it without 230.
um so my general feeling on this stuff
is 230 content moderation all of it just
to be very clear is that none of this is
easy or simple and there really isn't a
there is not a clearly defined way
forward to say police the internet or
regulate the internet there isn't one
um my point is that the the impact of
these platforms on society is inarguably
huge
um that some of these Farms are
politically motivated and funded or just
ideologically motivated and funded and
that should be called out and that we
shouldn't as Citizens sit on the
sidelines and just throw up our hands
and say well this stuff's too
complicated we shouldn't do anything we
should start to look at what we can do
what however that looks I'm not
convinced that's by reforming 230
personally but I'm also not I'm not the
head of Ethics at Berkeley like honey
foreign
how do you how do you look at the
revelations of things like the Twitter
files and and reason got a cache of
documents from Facebook where you know
this is also something not quite new but
it you know it became apparent that
there was a huge amount of government
censorship without calling it that where
you know people in both the Trump
Administration the bide Administration
we can certainly assume you know George
W bush and Obama as well saying to
platforms hey de-prioritize that kill
this don't push this
um does that change the complexity of
the task that uh that is at hand that
this idea that there is private you know
the private sector and the public sector
public speech private speech is kind of
out the window now
I think that what it does which is good
is it shows the specificity of it which
is something we're talking about in the
film that there are ideologies at play
there are political players at play it
isn't just the Town Square there are
people with agendas that are funded
funded agendas that are giving that are
using this golly you as parasocial
influencer to say very specific things
or to attempt behind the scenes to
curtail the saying of very specific
things so I actually think it's
important that we understand that
politics and and certain uh players are
involved in trying to shape the language
or curtail the language that's out there
I think that's the look these are the
beginning of conversations that we need
to have this this is by no means the end
of anything I I've got a last question
because I know you've got to run in a
minute um you directed another great
documentary called Deep Web about the
Ross Albrecht Saga and as such you know
I'm sure you're well aware of the that
encrypted communication Messengers and
platforms and decentralized alternatives
to YouTube have taken off as well as
centralized competitors like Rumble how
does that change the situation in terms
of how you think about these issues of
radicalization and misinformation and
Free Speech If there really is
increasingly no Central node to kind of
enforce any of this
I think that there is because I think at
the end of the day the large-scale
populace is mostly on the main platforms
the the numbers of the of the platforms
you just mentioned or or even Silk Road
that was my problem with the way Ross
was being treated Ross Albrecht in that
instance because he was being called a
Kingpin
um and you know even the drugs that were
being sold there were like the amount of
money and that was like what you'd get
on a street corner in Idaho right
um so they're actually fairly small
um the and I do worry about the breaking
of encryption around regulation which
we're starting to see in the EU as a
potential problem with the way they're
coming at regulating the internet that
would also potentially destroy
encryption which would be incredibly
dangerous for a lot of people who rely
on encryption for their safety
um so I think that that uh I'm a big
believer as you both of you guys well
know in um The Innovation and the
Freedom of Information and encryption
and open source technology but I don't
see that being I mean nor can it be
stopped but I don't see it being stopped
I just don't think that's the primary
way that the average people get their
information Alex what is the best way to
uh catch the YouTube effect
uh well we will be on digital on August
8th so we'll really be everywhere
especially I mean in any
English-speaking country I think we're
hitting other places internationally a
little later but uh you'll be able to
find us on sort of your usual platforms
you can go to my website alexwinter.com
and find us but we will be very easy to
see on August 8th right now we're in
Select theaters uh final final question
you you were talking briefly before
about participatory culture essentially
and this is there's a long Arc again as
the production costs and consumption
costs of of media become cheaper we
could look back at this for 500 years or
50 years or 10 years
um participatory culture seems to be the
answer
um make the final case like how should
people get off the sidelines in order to
enter the scrum to fight for the world
that they want is YouTube the medium for
that uh primarily or
I think that you know and this is maybe
a it's not an intentionally provocative
thing to say but I think people need to
lean into these Technologies and not
away from them I think that they're a
big part of our life and you have to get
involved I know my kids are safe because
I'm on YouTube I know who these people I
know who the good apples are in the bad
it's like that's parenting right it's
just like I wouldn't send my kid into a
neighborhood without knowing the
neighborhood or let them be with someone
that I didn't think was safe
um all three of my kids have been on
YouTube their entire life not one of
them got like black pill to Red pilled
or whatever whatever it is the kids say
um so uh it's you know I think leaning
in
um I think having an awareness of these
Technologies are not necessarily good or
bad they are just a part of human
evolution and Innovation so be part of
them use them understand them be
Discerning uh so I think that you're in
their participation can come from
wherever like you were saying about
Contra points like it comes from
wherever your strength is
um and and and really understanding
what's going on in the world in sort of
a broad way
thank you so much Alex Winter the new
movie is the YouTube effect thanks again
for talking to reason
yeah it was great as always you had
great questions